hold the string between your thumb and
your forefinger just hold it now just
while you're holding that still mentally
you have the idea it's moving back and
forth wider and wider see it's already
doing that okay just change the idea in
your mind and instead of swinging it
like that it's going to start swinging
like this in a different direction
[Music]
see now mentally have the idea that it's
going to start making circles just
mentally have the idea it's going to
start to make yourself there you are see
circles a bigger and bigger circles
there you are oh my Heavens you see your
expectancy determines outcome
and as long as you're not attached to
the outcome the outcome will be
guaranteed this is living proof that
every cell in your body is eavesdropping
on your internal diet